I would just scratch my own forehead and
not because I was thinking because I
wasn't thinking hey guys welcome to a
new segment that I'm calling grayscale
where I guess stuff in today's edition
I'm gonna try and guess way around
things I think will be popular for
spring 2015 let's get into it my first
prediction is by adding different forms
of tattoos different forms of body
jewelry and possibly different forms of
body hair will be very trendy for spring
2015 sometimes the easiest way for a non
creative person to express themselves so
through piercings and tattoos was it
really boiled down to needles super huge
spring 2015
founding babies North West Siri the
Royal baby all those babies I have just
such condescending faces they've seen
too much too soon in their lives
babies are becoming self-aware and it
turns out babies are [ __ ]
condescending babies are gonna be all
over the place spring 2015 really only
everywhere on everything figure it out
okay your parents have already invaded
your facebook and they're kind of
getting into Twitter and Instagram so
the only safe place you have left is the
super self serving platform of snapchat
vanity is a commodity people want social
media apps with less thought involved
snapchat special tampons feels like one
shark tank away from blowing up athletic
wear and real clothing this is not so
much a trend as more just my hope that
sweatpants become just pants I only drew
Pickles don't know why but I'm pretty
sure spring 2015 is gonna be your season
family where it's already happening a
lot of people have been going for those
messy Bob's girls like their hair like
they don't like their tinder dates a
messy bob for you have you
trend for spring 2015 I'm looking at you
tumblr more look at tumblr as more kids
are just being sad for the sake of being
sex I think it makes them interesting
I'm sorry I'm laughing at it I know
people have really sincere hard times
and struggles but it just seems like
it's now becoming a thing to get
attention
way less curse dogs and dog clothing are
already pretty popular
what about making dog clothing with
pockets for your personal possessions
you're never gonna leave your dog in the
airport when you board a flight but have
I left my purse yes think about it there
you go there are my Grace's guesses for
spring 2015 trends now we wait I don't
know my friend mamrie Hart follow her on
youtube if you're not a dumb-dumb loses
her debit cards more than I've ever seen
but she loves her dog beans heart more
than I've ever seen so beans heart had a
little sweater with a pocket for her
debit card problem solved she would
never ever ever lose that debit card
who's the genius now Kanye probably
still you I don't understand how your
brain works